OK GOOD MORNING, THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WILL COME TO ORDER
UH, GOOD MORNING. THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US FOR THIS MEETING. UH,
SENATE WELCOMES THE PUBLIC IN
PERSON AND WE ARE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE
OLD STREET BUILDING. I ASK ALL
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE BE
PRESENT IN ROOM 2200 SO WE CAN
ESTABLISH OUR QUORUM AND BEGIN
OUR HEARING. WE HAVE 11 BILLS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA, FIVE OF WHICH
ARE ON CONSENT. AH AH! FILE
NUMBER TWO S¼ B 1048 CENTER
JONES FILE NUMBER EIGHT. THREE
11. IS THAT? WHAT UH HUH BY THE
COMMITTEE ON LOCAL GOVERNMENT,
UM AND THEN I WANT TO JUST A
LITTLE BIT OF HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS
NUMBER ONE AND SEVEN ITEM ONE IS
S¼ B 917 AND, UH, 915 SORRY, S¼,
B 915 AND ALSO S¼ B 1494 BY
SENATOR GLASER. UM, BOTH OF
THOSE HAVE BEEN PULLED BY THE
AUTHORS. WE EXPECT TO HEAR THOSE
BILLS AT OUR APRIL 17TH HEARING.
AND UH, ALSO, BY THE WAY, UH,
SENATOR GLASER WILL NOT BE
PRESENT TODAY. I SEE WE DON'T
HAVE A QUORUM YET. ASSISTANCE SO
, UH, WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON AS A
COMMITTEE. SUB COMMITTEE SUB
COMMITTEE. AS A SUB COMMITTEE.
AND WHEN WE GET MORE THEN WE'LL
GO ON, OK? WE'RE GOING TO HEAR
FROM OUR FIRST, UM OUT THERE.
WE'RE GONNA ACCOMMODATE SENATOR
ARCHULETA, UH TO GO FIRST. UM
WELCOME, AND I THINK YOU WILL BE
PRESENTING SENATOR STERN'S FIRST
SENATOR STEARNS. YEAH. YOU WANNA
GO TO THE YOU'RE GONNA GO TO THE
PODIUM? AND. WELL, GOOD MORNING,
EVERYONE. GOOD MORNING, AND, UH,
MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS. UH, I
WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN AND
ACKNOWLEDGE. UH, THE, UH, THE
ACKNOWLEDGE AND SUGGEST THE
AMENDMENT ON PAGE FIVE OF THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AND AS YOU
HAD MENTIONED, I'M PRESENTING ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR STERN. AND HE
WILL CERTAINLY CONSIDER
INCLUDING THE AMENDMENTS IN THIS
BILL SHOULD THE BILL ADVANCE
THROUGH THE SENATE ENERGY
COMMITTEE WHERE THEY, UH,
CONSIDER SUCH MATTERS. AND
SENATE BILL 1251 SEEKS TO
IMPROVE MANY MOSQUITO VECTOR
CONTROL DISTRICTS IN THE
CAPACITY TO PROTECT PUBLIC
HEALTH AND CONSTITUENTS FROM THE
GROWING PROBLEM OF MOSQUITOES.
AND I'M ASSUMING SENATOR STERN
ASKED ME TO STEP IN BECAUSE I
SAT ON THE L, A COUNTY VECTOR
CONTROL FOR 12 YEARS, UH,
REPRESENTING THE DISTRICT THAT I
SERVE SPEAK RIVERA AND THE
SURROUNDING AREAS AND, UH,
VECTOR CONTROL IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT TO THE STATE OF THE
COUNTY, THE CITIES AND
EVERYTHING ELSE, AND I THINK
THAT'S WHY HE PROBABLY TAPPED ME
. HE MUST HAVE HEARD ABOUT THAT
THOUGHT IT WAS A SECRET, BUT
WE'LL CONTINUE. WELL MANY OF US
SIMPLY EXPERIENCE A MOSQUITO
BITE AS SOMETHING IRRITATING.
THESE TINY PEST CAN TRANSFER
SOME REALLY, REALLY SERIOUS
DISEASES WITH A SINGLE BITE THAT
CAN RESULT IN VERY, VERY SEVERE
ILLNESSES. AS WE ALL KNOW, UH,
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY AND
SUPPORT ON THE BILL IS VANESSA.
GINA UH, REPRESENTING THE
MOSQUITO AND VECTOR CONTROL
ASSOCIATION, AND JODY HOMAN, THE
MANAGER OF THE CONSOLIDATED
MOSQUITO ABATEMENT DISTRICT.
COVERING PARTS OF FRESNO AND
KING COUNTY. AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOU I VOTE ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR STERN. THANK YOU. UH,
THANK YOU, SENATOR. CHULETA, UM,
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO YOUR, UH,
TO LEAD WITNESSES. BUT I, I JUST
WANT TO REMIND US THAT EACH SIDE
WILL BE PERMITTED TO LEAD
WITNESSES, AND WE HAVE TWO
MINUTES EACH FOR THEIR TESTIMONY
. ALL OTHERS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
MUST LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS TO
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION,
SO LET'S HEAR FROM OUR LEAD
WITNESSES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MADAM CHAIR, MR VICE CHAIR OF
VANESSA KAHINA WITH Kò P PUBLIC
AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF THE
MOSQUITO AND VECTOR CONTROL
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA. WE'RE
PLEASED TO SPONSOR SB 1251. THIS
BILL WOULD ALLOW MOSQUITO
CONTROL DISTRICTS TO REQUEST AND
ENTER INTO AN AGREEMENT WITH
THEIR LOCAL UTILITY CORPORATION
TO MANAGE MOSQUITO PRODUCTION BY
FINDING ACCESSING TREATING AND
SURVEILLING MOSQUITOES AND
UTILITY VAULTS. MY COLLEAGUE
WHO'S GOING TO JOIN ME TODAY IS
WORKS TO PROTECT HER RESIDENTS
FROM INVASIVE SPECIES OF
MOSQUITOES THAT SPREAD DISEASES
AND ARE MUCH MORE LIKELY TO
REPRODUCE. IN THE WARMER
CLIMATES WE'RE FACING. SHE'LL
DISCUSS WHY UTILITY VAULTS AND
ACCESSING THEM ARE UNIQUE
PROBLEM AND WHY WE NEED THIS
BILL AS A SOLUTION. MOSQUITO
CONTROL AGENCIES HAVE
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THEIR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES TO TREAT THE SOURCES
OF MOSQUITO PRODUCTION, AND MOST
ARE CO-OPERATIVE AND PRODUCTIVE.
ALL MOSQUITO CONTROL AGENCIES
ARE SEEING RISING TEMPERATURES
PAIRED WITH THE WAY THAT THE
BUILT ENVIRONMENT TRAPS WATER AS
SOMETHING THAT MUST BE TAKEN
SERIOUSLY AND ROUTINELY BEFORE
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS OCCUR SO
THAT LOCAL CO-OPERATION IS VERY
CRITICAL. HOWEVER OF THE PAST 10
YEARS, WE'VE SEEN A LOT OF
INCONSISTENCY IN OUR ABILITY TO
DEVELOP THOSE COOPER PLANS, WITH
SOME UTILITIES RESULTING IN THE
INCREASED AND UNTREATED MOSQUITO
PRODUCTION WE SEE IN SOME OF
THESE AREAS. THIS APPROACH
PROVIDES A LOT OF FLEXIBILITY,
GIVING UTILITIES SIX MONTHS TO
DEVELOP A PLAN IN ACCORD WITH
THEIR MOSQUITO CONTROL DISTRICT
ONLY WHEN REQUESTED. WE HAVE
MEMBERS WHO ARE UNABLE TO
DEVELOP CONSISTENT PLANS TO
TREAT UTILITY VAULTS. BUT OTHER
MOSQUITO CONTROL AGENCIES WHO
CAN DEMONSTRATE BEST PRACTICES
TO COMBAT DISEASE SPREADING
MOSQUITOES. IF THIS COULD HAVE
BEEN ADDRESSED LOCALLY IN THE
PAST MANY YEARS, IT WOULD HAVE
FOR THOSE REASONS. WE ARE
PLEASED TO SPONSOR SB 1251. AND
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
. MY NAME IS JODY HOLMAN. I AM
THE DISTRICT MANAGER OF THE
CONSOLIDATED MOSQUITO ABATEMENT
DISTRICT, AN INDEPENDENT SPECIAL
DISTRICT IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
THAT COVERS JUST OVER 1000
SQUARE MILES, AND WE COVER
CITIES LIKE THE CITY OF SELMA,
UH, CLOVIS AND PART OF THE CITY
OF FRESNO. I'M ALSO A MEMBER OF
THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS FOR THE
MOSQUITO AND VECTOR CONTROL
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
SERVE AS THE SOUTH SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY REPRESENTATIVE ON THE
BOARD, PUTTING ME IN CONSTANT
COMMUNICATION WITH DISTRICT
MANAGERS AROUND THE STATE. OUR
DISTRICT AND MANY OTHERS IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA HAVE IDENTIFIED BELOW
GROUND UTILITY VAULTS AS A
SOURCE OF MOSQUITO PRODUCTION.
UTILITY VAULT LIDS ARE DESIGNED
WITH EVENTS THAT ALLOW AIR TO
ESCAPE. HOWEVER THESE VENTS ALSO
ALLOW WATER TO ENTER WATER FROM
PRECIPITATION, EVENTS OR MORE
COMMONLY, LANDSCAPE IRRIGATION
CAN ACCUMULATE IN VAULTS AND
CREATE PERFECT MOSQUITO
DEVELOPMENT CONDITIONS. A SINGLE
VAULT CAN PRODUCE HUNDREDS OF
MOSQUITOES THAT CAN EXIT THE
ENCLOSURE ONTO A RESIDENT FRONT
LAWN, WHILE ENCLOSURES ARE NOT
INTENDED TO HOLD WATER MORE THAN
50% OF THE ENCLOSURES WE'VE
INSPECTED HOLD ENOUGH WATER FOR
MOSQUITO DEVELOPMENT. OUT OF THE
APPROXIMATE 2600 ENCLOSURES
INSPECTED BY MY DISTRICT. EARLY
IN THE SEASON, 10% WERE FOUND TO
BE BREEDING MOSQUITOES DURING
THE SUMMER MONTHS. MOSQUITO
PRODUCTION INCREASES
SIGNIFICANTLY IF ENCLOSURES ARE
LEFT UNTREATED, THIS NUMBER
COULD RISE SIGNIFICANTLY
THREATENING NEARBY RESIDENTS.
WHY DOES THIS MATTER? OUR
DISTRICTS ARE ON THE FRONT LINES
OF ADDRESSING THE CLIMATE CHANGE
ADAPTATION CHALLENGES OVER THE
PAST DECADE. WE CAN WE HAVE SEEN
AN INFLUX OF INVASIVE MOSQUITO
SPECIES THAT CAN CARRY AND
TRANSMIT EXOTIC DISEASES SUCH AS
DENGUE, YELLOW FEVER, ZIKA AND
OTHERS. THIS NEW THREAT COULD
OVERWHELM OUR DISTRICTS UNLESS
WE TAKE ADAPTATIONS SERIOUSLY.
PREVENT THE CRISIS BEFORE IT
HAPPENS. VAULTS THESE VAULTS ARE
PRIME EXAMPLE OF THE KIND OF
THREATS THAT WE NEED TO ADDRESS
NOW FROM 2014 TO 2022. WE WORKED
WITH OUR LOCAL UTILITY PROVIDER
TO SAFELY TREAT AND MONITOR
UTILITY VAULTS, BUT CHANGES IN
MANAGEMENT AND A LACK OF FORMAL
PLANS ERODED THOSE GAINS. WE ARE
NOW WITHOUT ANY SYSTEMATIC
PROCESS FOR FINDING AND TREATING
VAULTS THAT ARE A SOURCE OF
MOSQUITO PRODUCTION. THIS
PROBLEM IS REPLICATE, REPLICATED
ALL OVER THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND
THROUGHOUT MUCH OF THE STATE.
THOSE MOSQUITO CONTROL DISTRICTS
WHO HAVE MANAGED TO GAIN SOME
LEVEL OF COOPER, OPERATION FROM
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITY COMPANIES
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY HAVE FOUND
THAT COMMUNICATION IS OFTEN
INCONSISTENT. ADDITIONALLY THE
LEVEL OF SUPPORT AND
CO-OPERATION IN ACHIEVING
EFFICIENT ACCESS AND TREATMENT
IS ALSO INCONSISTENT DESPITE
SIGNING MULTIPLE NON DISCLOSURE
AGREEMENTS TO OBTAIN UPDATED
DATA SETS ON VAULT LOCATIONS TO
ADDRESS NEWLY BUILT HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS. WE CONTINUE TO
WAIT FOR THE UTILITY COMPANY TO
PROVIDE DATA THEY AGREED TO
PROVIDE OUR DISTRICT HAS
ROUTINELY OUTLINED THE NUMBER OF
TREATMENTS TO BE MADE WHERE THE
TREATMENTS NEED TO BE MADE AND A
TIMELY TREATMENT. UH, SCHEDULE
BASED ON RESOURCES. CARVER YEAR
TO YEAR. THESE REQUESTS ARE
CONSISTENTLY NOT ADDRESSED FOR
THOSE REASONS, HAVING A
REQUIREMENT TO DEVELOP A COOPER
PLAN WITH INVESTOR OWNED UTILITY
COMPANIES WITHIN SIX MONTHS OF
THE MOSQUITO CONTROL DISTRICT'S
REQUEST TO DO SO IS A COMMON
SENSE MEASURE TO PREVENT WHAT
COULD BE A PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. UM DO WE HAVE ANY FURTHER
SUPPORT? UH, WITNESSES HERE.
GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR BETSY
ARMSTRONG, ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
COMMITTEE AND CHAIR. MY NAME IS
BRAYDEN DOYLE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICT
ASSOCIATION. WE ARE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. OK DO WE
HAVE ANY LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESSES? NÓ SAY, LEAD ANYONE
HERE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. OK, SEE
NONE. UM YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS?
I'M SORRY. QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS. YES, SENATOR. OUR
QUESTION FOR VECTOR CONTROL. UM
THIS IS A SERIOUS HEALTH CRISIS.
UH, THE MOSQUITO POPULATION HAS
BEEN EXPLODING, ESPECIALLY
LITTLE GUYS THAT YOU CAN'T
REALLY SEE. AND CAN YOU DESCRIBE
SOME OF THE UM, ENVIRONMENTS OR
THE KIDS. I I'VE HEARD THAT THEY
CAN BREED IN A THIMBLE IN IN A
IN A BOTTLE CAP. UH, IF THERE'S
A BOTTLE CAP LEFT OUT WITH WATER
, UH, SO THAT PEOPLE UNDERSTAND
HOW SERIOUS THIS IS AND WHY IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT FOR US TO ADDRESS
THIS. YEAH SO, UM, THE BIG
CHALLENGE THAT WE DEAL WITH UP
AND DOWN THE STATE IS A NEW
INVASIVE SPECIES, AEDES AEGYPTI
AND AEDES ALBOPICTUS. MULTIPLE
INVASIVE SPECIES. UM, THESE ARE
DIFFERENT FROM OUR NATIVE
SPECIES IN THAT THEY WILL BREED
IN VERY SMALL AMOUNTS OF WATER.
UNLIKE SOME OF OUR NATIVE
SPECIES THAT YOU WILL FIND IN
LARGER WATER BODIES, LIKE A LOT
OF PEOPLE SEE SWAMPS, MARSHES,
THINGS LIKE THAT. AND THINK OF
MOSQUITOES. THEY DON'T THINK OF,
UM MAYBE SOME THAT WAS LEFT IN
THEIR BACKYARD. THAT'S
ACCUMULATING SPRINKLER WATER,
BUT ABSOLUTELY THOSE THINGS CAN
BREED MOSQUITOES. UM AND THE
UTILITY ENCLOSURES ALSO ARE, UM,
DENSE IN URBAN RESIDENTIAL AREAS
THAT ARE ALSO PRODUCING THESE
MOSQUITOES AS WELL AND THEY
CATCH RUNOFF. A LOT OF TIMES
FROM THE IRRIGATION THAT PEOPLE
ARE DOING SO THEY'RE A PRETTY
MUCH YEAR ROUND IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN MANY PARTS OF THE
STATE DON'T EXPERIENCE ANY
PRECIPITATION EVENTS DURING PEAK
MOSQUITO SEASON, WHICH IS JULY,
AUGUST AND SEPTEMBER. UM, BUT
RESIDENTS. BUSINESSES CONTINUE
TO DO LANDSCAPING IRRIGATION
THAT ENTERS WATER INTO THESE
SYSTEMS, SO THEY WILL BREED
MOSQUITOES, UM THROUGHOUT THE
MOSQUITO DEVELOPMENT SEASON, AND
EVEN THOUGH THE VAULTER ACTUALLY
DESIGNED TO DRAIN OFF WATER UM,
A LOT OF TIMES, LIKE ALL OTHER
THINGS THAT YOU THOUGHT YOU
DESIGNED TO DRAIN OFF. IT
DOESN'T ALWAYS DRAIN OFF. AND SO
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR THE I Ó U S¼
TO GET OUT THERE AND YES, ITS
INSPECTIONS, BUT THIS LOOKS LIKE
IT PROVIDES A BACKSTOP TO THEM.
NOT DOING THAT PROCESS, JUST
LIKE IF THEY WERE NOT DOING THE
CLEARANCE OF OVER OVERHEAD WIRES
, UH, DOING FIRE MITIGATION
UNDERNEATH. THIS IS ACTUALLY
WHAT THEY HAVE TO DO FOR THESE
VAULTS TO ENSURE OUR SAFETY.
THAT'S CORRECT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. SENATOR THIS DOES PROVIDE
THAT BACKSTOP IN THAT WE'VE HAD
IS, MISS HOLMAN INDICATED
DIFFERENT LEVELS OF COOPER
OPERATION, BUT WE ALSO HAVE SOME
BEST PRACTICES. THE UTILITY IS
ABLE TO DO THAT ON THEIR OWN IN
CO ORDINATION WITH THE MOSQUITO
CONTROL AGENCY. SO WE FIND THIS
TO HAVE A LOT OF FLEXIBILITY IN
TERMS OF THE APPROACH IN THE ON
RAMP FOR IT. I'D WANT TO BE
WORKING REALLY CAREFULLY WITH
OUR VECTOR CONTROL TO MAKE SURE
THAT OUR AGENCY WOULDN'T BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR GIVING US ALL
THESE MOSQUITOES WITH THAT, UH,
I APPRECIATE. UH UH, SENATOR
STERN'S BILL, UH, ADDRESSING
THIS, I THINK IT'S IT MAKES A
LOT OF SENSE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR CHULETA
HE WELL, I I'D LIKE TO JUST
CLOSE BY SAYING THANK YOU, AND
IT'S SO IMPORTANT AS WE'RE
APPROACHING THE SUMMER MONTHS.
CHILDREN PEOPLE DON'T EVEN
REALIZE THAT THE DANGER THAT WE
HAVE AND ALL THE PEOPLE IN THE
VE CONTROL INDUSTRY ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. THEIR MISSION. KEEP
US SAFE, AND I'M SO PROUD TO
PRESENT THIS BILL ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR STERN. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR EYE VOTE. THANK
YOU. AND BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
THE QUORUM, WE WILL NOT BE
TAKING THIS BILL UP UNTIL GET
MORE OF OUR MEMBERS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH TO OUR WITNESSES FOR
BEING HERE. SENATOR ARCHULETA.
DO YOU WANNA PROCEED WITH THE
NEXT BILL? THIS IS S¼ 1418.
OKAY? THERE YOU GO. ONCE AGAIN.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT MY BILL
AND THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS. UH I
WOULD LIKE TO START BY THANKING
THE CHAIR AND HER STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH ME ON THIS BILL AND
THE NOTE THAT I AGREE TO ACCEPT
ALL OF THE COMMITTEE SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS AS OUTLINED IN TAB
FIVE AND SIX AND THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS AS THE CHAIR OF THE
SELECT COMMITTEE ON HYDROGEN
ENERGY. IT HAS COME TO MY
ATTENTION THAT PIVOTAL COMPONENT
OF OUR TRANSITION TOWARDS A
CLEANER, MORE SUSTAINABLE MODE
OF TRANSPORTATION. HYDROGEN
FUELING STATIONS ARE AT THE
TIMES NOT BEING BUILT OR
UNNECESSARILY DELAYED DUE TO AN
OVERLY BURDENSOME PERMITTING
PROCESS BY LOCAL MUNICIPALITIES.
IN SOME COUNTIES AS WELL. SENATE
BILL 1418 ADDRESSES THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE AS HYDROGEN HAS
SHOWN GREAT POTENTIAL TOWARDS
DECARBONIZING, OUR HEAVY DUTY
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR. SENATE
BILL 118 TRANSCENDS SIMPLE LOCAL
ORDINANCES OR MUNICIPAL CONCERNS
AND RATHER ADDRESSES THE
STATEWIDE IMPERATIVE. THIS BILL
RECOGNIZES THE VITAL NEED FOR
CONSISTENT STANDARDS ACROSS ALL
JURISDICTIONS. TO FACILITATE THE
PROMPT AND COST EFFECTIVE
DEPLOYMENT OF THESE CRITICAL
ZERO EMISSION FUELING STATIONS.
SENATE BILL 1418 UNDERSCORES OUR
LEGISLATIVE COMMITMENT TO
FOSTERING ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
INFRASTRUCTURE WHILE MITIGATING
BARRIERS TO THE INSTALLATION OF
HYDROGEN FUELING STATIONS. WE'VE
GOT TO OPEN THE DOORS AND
WELCOME THESE STATIONS INTO OUR
STATE SENATE BILL 1418 BRINGS
PARITY TO THE ELECTRIC VEHICLE
PERMITTING PROCESS BY
STREAMLINING THE ADMINISTRATIVE
APPROVAL PROCESS FOR HYDROGEN
FUELING STATIONS IN THE SAME WAY
THAT WE DO FOR THE CHARGING
STATIONS. SPECIFICALLY SENATE
BILL 1418 MANDATES THAT CITIES
AND COUNTIES MUST ADOPT AN
ORDINANCE AND CHECKLIST THAT
CREATES AN EXPEDITED,
STREAMLINED PERMITTING PROCESS
FOR HYDROGEN. STATIONS THIS
DIRECTIVE IS DESIGNED TO
EXPEDITE PROCEDURES AND ENSURE
THAT CITIZENS HAVE ACCESS TO
CLEAN ENERGY OPTIONS WITHOUT
UNNECESSARILY ADMINISTRATIVE
HURDLES. WHILE SENATE BILL 1018
STREAMLINES THE PRINTING PROCESS
, HEALTH AND SAFETY REMAINS TOP
PRIORITY. MY PREVIOUS BILL
SENATE BILL 1291, WHICH PASSED
AND WAS SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR
ENSURES HYDROGEN FUELING STATION
PERMITS ADHERE TO STRINGENT
HEALTH AND SAFETY COMPONENTS AND
PERFORMANCE STANDARDS. SENATE
BILL 1418 KEEPS THESE CORE
COMPONENTS IN PLACE. FURTHERMORE
TO ADDRESS PHYSICAL AND
PROCEDURAL CONCERNS. SENATE BILL
1418 PHASES IN THE REQUIREMENTS
THAT MOST CITIES AND COUNTIES IN
THE STATE WILL NOT HAVE TO
DEVELOP AN ORDINANCE UNTIL
SEPTEMBER OF 2026. WELL AFTER
GÓMEZ RELEASES ITS MODEL
ORDINANCE AND CHECKLIST FOR
HYDROGEN, FUELING STATIONS
PERMIT IN CONCLUSION, MADAM
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
CALIFORNIA HAS MORE FUEL SELL
ELECTRIC VEHICLES AND THE
HYDROGEN STATIONS NECESSARY TO
FUEL THEM THAN ANY OTHER STATE
IN THE NATION. AND WITH
CALIFORNIA'S RECENT SUCCESS IN
SECURING SUBSTANTIAL FEDERAL
FUNDING FOR CLEAN RENEWABLE
HYDROGEN INITIATIVES THROUGH THE
ALLIANCE OF RENEWABLE, CLEAN
ENERGY, HYDROGEN. ALSO KNOWN AS
ARCHES. THE TIMELY PASSAGE OF
SENATE BILL 1418 IS ESSENTIAL TO
TAKE FULL ADVANTAGE OF THESE
FEDERAL DOLLARS TO EXPEDITE THE
DEVELOPMENT AND DEPLOYMENT OF
HYDROGEN INFRASTRUCTURE IN TURN,
FACILITATING OUR STATE'S
TRANSITION TO A CLEANER
TRANSPORTATION FUTURE. SENATE
BILL 14 REPRESENTS A PIVOTAL
STEP TOWARDS REALIZING OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL STEWARDSHIP AND
OBLIGATION. UH, AN ADVANCING OUR
SUSTAINABLE TRANSPORTATION
OBJECTIVES. FOR THESE REASONS, I
RESPECTFULLY AFTER YOU I VOTE
AND TODAY WITH ME, I HAVE, UH IN
SUPPORT THERESA COOK,
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
HYDROGEN COALITION, WHO CAN ALSO
ASSIST IN ANSWERING ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HAVE. AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FEAR. I VOTE ONCE AGAIN. THANK
YOU, SENATOR. MS. COOK. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS TERESA
COOK HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HYDROGEN COALITION.
VERY PLEASED TO BE IN SUPPORT OF
MR ARCHULETA 1418. THIS BILL, AS
NOTED, WOULD ALIGN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE PERMITTING FOR
HYDROGEN REFUELING STATIONS FOR
FUEL CELL ELECTRIC VEHICLES WITH
THAT OF CHARGING STATIONS FOR
BATTERY ELECTRIC VEHICLES IN THE
A. R B'S ANNUAL A B EIGHT REPORT
THEY NOTE. UM YOU KNOW VERY
REGULARLY. THAT PERMITTING IS
ONE OF THE BIGGEST CAUSES OF
PROJECT DELAYS AND THE UPFRONT
CHECKLIST IN PARTICULAR THAT
THIS BILL PROVIDES IS WIDELY
POPULAR AMONGST OUR HYDROGEN
FUELING STATION DEVELOPERS.
ACCORDING TO THE AIR BOARD. FUEL
CELL VEHICLES WILL BE 20% OF THE
PASSENGER MARKET AND MUCH HIGHER
AND HEAVY DUTY APPLICATIONS TO
MR ARCHULETA POINT. IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE START CREATING
THE OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE BUILD
OUT OF THESE STATIONS AS QUICKLY
AS POSSIBLE. UM, AS WE ALL KNOW,
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS TO BE IN
PLACE BEFORE THESE VEHICLES ARE
DEPLOYED. AND SO FOR THAT REASON
, 1418 IS CRITICAL FOR US TO
MEET OUR ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
GOALS. BUT MOST PARTICULARLY FOR
HOUSEHOLDS THAT ARE LIVING IN
MULTI UNIT DWELLINGS THAT DON'T
HAVE ACCESS TO GARAGE CHARGING.
WE HAVE A LOT OF SUPER COMMUTERS
IN THE STATE, A LOT OF FOLKS
THAT NEED LARGER SIZE VEHICLES
THAT FUEL CELL VEHICLES ARE
UNIQUELY POSITIONED TO SERVE. SO
FOR THOSE REASONS WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SUPPORT TODAY AND
ENCOURAGE YOUR SUPPORT TODAY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
UH, DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF S¼ B
1418. PLEASE COME UP. THANK YOU,
MADAM. CHAIR BOBBY KANE,
CALIFORNIA HYDROGEN CAR OWNERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR
BERNICE GIMENEZ KRIEGER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TRUCKING ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS, VINCE
WE MAJA WITH THEIR PRODUCTS AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR JACKIE ON THIS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA FUELS
AND CONVENIENCE ALLIANCE AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. RAN BACK 50
YEAR RESEARCHER AND AN ADVANCED
ENERGY 40 YEARS IN HYDROGEN. I
ENCOURAGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. UM DO
WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES? ANYONE
SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION? THE SB
1418. YES, PLEASE COME FORWARD.
GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR AND
DAMON CONKLIN WITH THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES. UH, FIRST AND
FOREMOST, WE WANNA, UH,
ACKNOWLEDGE AND APPRECIATE THE
WORK OF THE AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF
TO ADDRESS SOME OF OUR CONCERNS
WITH THE MOST RECENT AMENDMENTS.
UM DESPITE THESE AMENDMENTS, WE
STILL REMAIN OPPOSED UNLESS
AMENDED. CONTINUING UM, CITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE ARE VERY
SUPPORTIVE, UM, AND OF HELPING
THE STATE ADDRESS CLIMATE CHANGE
, AS WELL AS ACHIEVING THE
STATE'S TRANSPORTATION AND
CLIMATE GOALS FOR CITIES HAVE
BEEN LEADERS IN SUPPORTING
PROJECTS AND PROGRAMS TO REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS. WE
WOULD EVEN SUBMIT THAT YOU KNOW,
WE BELIEVE THE BASIC PREMISE OF,
UM OF THE INTENT OF THE BILL IN
THAT HYDROGEN IS A IS A, UH,
OFTEN IF NOT OVERLOOKED,
SOMETIMES PUSHED TO THE SIDE. UM
TECHNOLOGY, IN CONTRAST TO E VÆ
CHARGING AND WHEN WE LOOK AT,
UH, MEDIUM TO HEAVY DUTY AND
ADVANCED CLEAN FLEETS WE SEE
HYDROGEN IS REALLY A BETTER
OPTION IN MANY IN MANY, UH UH
UH, TEMPLATES AND, UH, SYSTEMS
HOWEVER, THIS BILL IS FRAMED ON
THIS FALSE PREMISE THAT CITIES
ARE THE BARRIERS. CITIES ARE THE
ONES THAT ARE INHIBITING THE, UH
, PROLIFERATION OF HYDROGEN
HUBS. UM IT TAKES A LOT OF
ENERGY TO PRODUCE. UM UH,
HYDROGEN THREE TO 3 TO 9 TIMES
MORE ENERGY THAN ELECTRIC FIELD,
CHARGING, UH, IT'S FOUR TIMES,
UH, THE PRICE OF GASOLINE 16
GALLONS OF GAS. UM THERE'S
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF COMPLEXITY
WITH THE ENGINEERING THE
STRUCTURE, TRANSPORTATION,
STORAGE, UH, ELECTRICAL CODES.
LACK OF CAPITAL INVESTMENT.
THESE ARE THE BARRIERS. UM LAST
MONTH, I THINK WE SAW MORE
APPLICATIONS WITHDRAWN, THEN
ACTUAL, PENDING APPLICATIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. I THINK,
THE CALIFORNIA HYDROGEN
COALITION'S OWN WEBSITE NOTED 18
PENDING APPLICATIONS. UH, FOR,
UH, THAT THAT ARE, UH, BEING
REVIEWED THROUGHOUT THE STATE,
AND WE'RE MAKING A ONE SIZE FITS
ALL POLICY HERE. UH, WHERE, UH,
EVERY CITY NÓ MATTER THEIR SIZE
NÓ MATTER THEIR FINANCIAL
RESOURCES MAY NEVER, EVER SEE AN
APPLICATION BEFORE THEM HAVE TO
DEVELOP THIS PERMITTING SYSTEM,
UM AND COMPETE WITH SOLAR AND E,
VÆ CHARGING AND OTHER EDICTS
FROM THE STATE THAT SAY THOU
SHALT DO THIS FIRST, UM SO YOU
KNOW WE WOULD LOVE TO WORK WITH
THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE TO SAY HEY,
IS THERE YOU KNOW A WAY THAT
THIS IS APPLICABLE TO THOSE
JURISDICTIONS THAT ACTUALLY
RECEIVE PERMITS? HAPPY TO DO SO,
UH, IT JUST DOESN'T FEEL, UH,
APPROPRIATE TO MAKE IT APPLY TO
EVERY JURISDICTION REGARDLESS OF
THEIR SIZE. AND FOR THOSE
REASONS WE REMAIN OPPOSED UNLESS
AMENDED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR
CONKLIN. UM ANYONE ELSE WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION? YES
CHRISTINA, WITH THE CENTER FOR
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY AND
OPPOSITION. I URGE THE COMMITTEE
TO LOOK AT SOME OF THE REPORTS
FROM IE, A AND OTHERS NOTING
THAT THIS DOES NOT MAKE SENSE
FROM AN ECONOMIC PERSPECTIVE.
THE STATE REALLY NEEDS TO LOOK
AT HOW IT SPENDS ITS LIMITED
DOLLARS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. SEE
NONE. UM MEMBERS. SENATOR I'LL
COME IN A LITTLE BIT, UM SO I AM
ALL FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF
HYDROGEN FUEL CELL AND THAT
TECHNOLOGY AND, UH, GETTING AS
MANY TRUCKS, CARS ET CETERA, AS
CAN BE DONE TO HELP CREATE A
CLEANER ENVIRONMENT FOR US. UM A
LOT OF THE SENTIMENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN EXPRESSED BY THE
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE LEAGUE
OF CITIES ARE SENT IN SENTIMENTS
THAT I HOLD, UH, ESPECIALLY
COMING FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
AND HAVING THE FRUSTRATIONS OF
WATCHING PROJECTS THAT WE REALLY
WANT DONE HELD UP BEYOND OUR
CONTROL. AND YOU KNOW, WE HAVE A
LOT OF REGULATIONS THAT WE HAVE
TO MAKE PEOPLE GO THROUGH IN
ORDER AND STUDIES, ETCETERA S¼.
ALL OF THOSE THINGS HAVE TO BE
DONE. THOSE ARE A LOT OF TIMES
OUTSIDE THE CONTROL OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. AND UH AND SO THEY
WIND UP. UM BEING THE PEOPLE GET
BLAMED BECAUSE THEY'RE
ULTIMATELY THE PERSON I HAVE TO
GIVE THE PERMIT. BUT IF ALL THE
BOXES AREN'T CHECKED FROM ALL OF
THESE OTHER THINGS, THEN, UM,
YOU KNOW THEY THEY'RE THE ONES
WHO WIND UP. UH HAVING TO TURN
IT DOWN AND, UH AND YOU KNOW
THEY I THINK A LOT OF
GOVERNMENTS THAT ARE UH, TRYING
DESPERATELY TO DO THIS
TECHNOLOGY. UM THEY'RE ALREADY
TRYING. AND UH, UNLESS WE
ADDRESS SOME OF THE OTHER ISSUES
THAT ARE ARE, UH, REALLY CAUSING
THESE DELAYS, UM AND SOME OF
THEM ARE NECESSARY AND SOME ARE
UNNECESSARY. AND WHEN YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT HYDROGEN FUEL, YOU
KNOW, THERE IS A PUBLIC
PERCEPTION OUT THERE. UH THE
PEOPLE DON'T WANT THINGS LIKE
THIS RUSHED THROUGH. UM, BECAUSE
THEY'RE AFRAID OF IT. UH,
THEY'RE AFRAID OF WHAT THEY WHAT
THEY VIEW AS YOU KNOW POTENTIAL
FOR, UH, FOR, UH, YOU KNOW,
EXPLOSIONS AND THINGS LIKE THAT.
AND MAYBE THOSE ARE UNFOUNDED
NOWADAYS BECAUSE OF THE
TECHNOLOGY THAT WE HAVE, BUT
IT'S STILL OUT THERE AND, UH SO
WE NEED TO BE COGNIZANT.
COGNIZANT OF THAT, UM, AND, UH
AND WHERE THEY'RE PLACED AND
WHAT THE REGULATIONS ARE AROUND
THEM BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
REGULATIONS. SOME OF THEM AREN'T
REGULATIONS THAT IT CAN BE
NECESSARILY SKIRTED AROUND. AND
UH AND SO, FOR THOSE REASONS,
I'M I'M, UH, NOT, UH, PROBABLY
GOING TO SUPPORT THE BILL. UM
BECAUSE I WOULD RATHER HAVE, UH,
THE CITIES. UH UH, REMAIN IN
FULL CONTROL OF BEING ABLE TO
GET THROUGH THESE PROCESSES AND
BE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE OR NOT
PARTICIPATE IF THEY'RE NOT IN
THAT POSITION, UH, TO
PARTICIPATE. UH SO, UM, WITH
THAT, UM, THAT'S KIND OF MY
THOUGHTS ON THE BILL. THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR. MAY I COMMENT, OK,
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
WITNESS WHO ARE COMING FORWARD.
THANK YOU. WE APPRECIATE IT. BUT
CALIFORNIA IS IN THE FOREFRONT
WITH HYDROGEN, AND THAT'S WHY
WHEN MY BILL SENATE BILL 1291
WAS PRESENTED TO THE COMMITTEES
AND WORKED ITS WAY THROUGH THE
SENATE ASSEMBLY AND THROUGH THE
GOVERNOR, IT WAS TO OPEN THE
DOORS TO THIS NEW TECHNOLOGY,
HYDROGEN FUEL CELL BATTERIES,
AND I WILL SHARE SOMETHING WITH
YOU ON A PERSONAL NOTE. I WENT
HOME AND TOLD MY WIFE THAT I'M
LOOKING SERIOUSLY, UH, AND
OBTAINING A FUEL CELL BATTERY
AUTOMOBILE. AND UH, I'M SORRY I
WENT BACK AND I SAID, I'M I'M
LOOKING TO BUY A HYDROGEN
AUTOMOBILE AND SHE GOES NOT IN
MY GARAGE AS YOU MENTIONED. SO
UH, WHY DID I EVEN ASK THAT
BECAUSE ONE OF MY STAFF MEMBERS
HAVE A COUPLE OF OUR SENATORS ON
THE TYPE OF CAR SO I WENT BACK
HOME, AND I SAID, I'M LOOKING AT
FUEL CELL BATTERY. CAR THAT GETS
400 MILES, UH, PER TANK. AND SHE
SAYS, WOW, WHEN DO WE GET IT?
AND, UH AND THEN I SAID, UH,
WE'RE GONNA KEEP LOOKING. WE
NEED TO FUEL CELL HYDROGEN
STATION TO BE ABLE TO GO. THAT
IS OUR OUR SETBACK. MY TWO TRIPS
TO JAPAN TO MEET WITH THEM AND
THEIR HYDROGEN PRODUCTION AND
EVERYTHING THAT'S DONE THERE. UH
THE INDUSTRY THAT I'VE MET WITH
TIME AND TIME AGAIN. ONE OF THE
THINGS I LEARNED IS SAFETY. AND
I GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE IF I HAD
TO DROP IF THIS WERE A DESK,
YEAH, AND I HAD A DROP OF GAS.
PUT IT RIGHT THERE AND A DROP OF
HYDROGEN AND I LIT THEM. THIS
WOULD BURN THROUGH THE TABLE
HYDROGEN WOULD DISSIPATE SAFE.
THAT'S ONE THING. THE OTHER
THING IS CALIFORNIA SEEK, UH,
$1.5 BILLION FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. MY RESOLUTION THAT
WE SIGNED ON AND WE SENT TO
WASHINGTON TO BRING THE HUB HERE
TO OPEN UP THE DOORS FOR CITIES
AND MUNICIPALITIES AND
BUSINESSES. GOOD LABOR ORIENTED,
UH, BUSINESSES UNION WAGE
BUSINESSES IN THE HYDROGEN
ENERGY THAT MONEY CAME SO NOW
WE'RE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHO
CAN PARTICIPATE IN THE FUTURE OF
HYDROGEN. AND I WILL TELL YOU
THIS SENATOR THAT IN CALIFORNIA
WE HAVE A TREASURE CHEST OF
ENERGY. YOU OPEN THAT UP, AND
WE'VE GOT FUEL CELL BATTERIES.
OF COURSE WE'VE GOT ENERGY
ELECTRIC. WE'VE GOT EVERYTHING
AND SOLAR AND WE HAVE GOT TO
UTILIZE EVERYTHING AND OUR OUR
POWER AND OUR POSSESSION IN IN
MY COMMUNITY. THERE MIGHT BE AN
EIGHT STORY APARTMENT HOUSE OR A
FOUR STORY APARTMENT HOUSE AND
NOT EVERYBODY CAN AFFORD THE,
UH, COST OF THESE ELECTRIC
VEHICLES. SO THEY SHOULD HAVE AN
OPTION. AND IF WE HAD THE
FUELING STATIONS, MAYBE THEY CAN
PURCHASE THESE. THESE UH,
VEHICLES, NOT AT THE COST OF THE
STATE OR OUR OUR OTHER, UH,
PUBLIC ENTITIES, BUT THE
INDIVIDUALS THEMSELVES NOW WE'RE
ASKING FOR THE CITIES TO
UNDERSTAND THAT THE CITIES WILL
DECIDE WHO COMES FIRST, A SOLAR
ENERGY OR HYDROGEN. IT'S UP TO
THEM. SO WE'RE NOT TAKING AWAY
THE CITY. UH, REQUIREMENTS THE
COST. THE CITY WILL AND LEVY
THOSE FEES, NOT THE STATE, SO
IT'S ALL BACK TO THE TO THE TO
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT. THE OTHER
THING IS THAT NOW THAT WE HAVE
THE $1.5 BILLION FROM ARCHERS
NOW PEOPLE ARE GOING TO START
LOOKING MORE, UH, VARIOUS
AUTOMOBILE INDUSTRIES. UH, WE
TALKED ABOUT THE PORT OF LOS
ANGELES, THE PORT OF LONG BEACH
AND THE VEHICLES THAT ARE THERE.
THEY'RE TRANSITIONING INTO
HYDROGEN AS WELL. THAT THE
TECHNOLOGY IS THERE. THE SAFETY
HAS ALREADY BEEN LOOKED AT, AND
WE HAVE TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
FUTURE OF THIS. ALL THIS BILL
DOES IS OPEN UP THE DOORS TO THE
MUNICIPALITIES, IT SAYS. YOU CAN
GO AHEAD AND PROCESS THESE
THINGS. AND YOU DO THE
PERMITTING. YOU'VE GOT THE
AUTHORITY AND BUT PUBLIC SAFETY
IS NUMBER ONE. WE'VE ALREADY
DONE THAT. SO THAT'S ALL WE'RE
DOING IS JUST OPENING UP THE
DOOR. NOW EVERY CITY WILL
PARTICIPATE BECAUSE NOT EVERY
CITY WILL HAVE AN APPLICANT THAT
WILL DO IT. BUT WE DON'T WANT TO
CLOSE THE DOORS. WE WANNA KEEP
THOSE DOORS OPEN FOR EVERYONE.
YES, SENATOR. I HAVE A QUICK
QUESTION. UM WHAT ARE SOME OF
THE REGULATORY AGENCIES THAT YOU
HAVE TO GO THROUGH TO BE ABLE
TO, UH, OPEN UP A HYDRO AND
CELL. HØI HØI HYDROGEN FUEL.
STATION STATION. UM ALL LOCAL WE
DON'T HAVE STATE LEVEL ISSUE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD. NÓ NÓ. WE DON'T
SO THE èC èC ISSUED YEARS AGO,
SORT OF A BLANKET EXEMPTION FOR
I THINK IT'S LIKE A NAG DECK OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT FOR S¼ FOR
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE AND
HYDROGEN REFUELING STRUCTURE SO
WE DON'T REALLY RUN INTO STATE
LEVEL ISSUES. UM WHEN IT COMES
TO PERMITTING, IT'S
PREDOMINANTLY LOCAL. OK THEN,
THEN WHERE THE HANG UP IN THE
PERMITTING LOCALLY. HONESTLY I
THINK THERE IS STILL SOME OF
WHAT YOU NOTED, WHICH IS THE
LACK OF FAMILIARITY AROUND
HYDROGEN. THERE ARE A LOT OF
FOLKS OUT THERE THAT ARE
HYDROGEN SKEPTICS AND THOSE
THINGS ARE PERMEATING BOTH IN A
STATE LEVEL THAT WE EXPERIENCE
SOMETIMES HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE FROM TIME TO TIME,
BUT ALSO LOCALLY AS WELL. SO YOU
KNOW, WE HAVE SEEN CITIES
OUTRIGHT REFUSE TO CONSIDER
ANYTHING RELATED TO HYDROGEN,
WHICH WAS PRETTY DEVASTATING. UM
WE HAVE SEEN FOLKS JUST
UNFAMILIAR WITH THE, UH, AMOUNT
OF RESEARCH AND RESOURCES THAT
ARE AVAILABLE ON HYDROGEN
REFUELING. ONE OF THE THINGS OUR
INDUSTRY DID VERY, VERY WELL IS
BEFORE A VEHICLE EVER CAME TO
MARKET OR A STATION WAS BUILT.
WE CAME UP WITH A SAFETY
STANDARDS WITH THE STATE FIRE
MARSHAL AND OTHERS ON THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE. UM YOU KNOW, GO
BIZ HAS A PERMITTING HANDBOOK.
THERE ARE PLENTY. THERE'S A
WEALTH OF RESOURCES OUT THERE
THAT ARE MEANT TO INFORM. CITY
AND COUNTY PERMITTING STAFF
ABOUT HOW TO DO THIS SAFELY AND
WELL, WE'RE STILL RUNNING INTO
CHALLENGES TO THE EXTENT THAT 20
. OR THAT 1418 ADDS A LITTLE BIT
OF URGENCY AND DEMAND TO FOCUS
IN ON THAT MORE. SO IS WHAT
WE'RE AFTER HERE. I MEAN, I'LL
REMIND YOU, SENATOR THAT
CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF THE THREE
LARGEST HYDROGEN PRODUCING
STATES. IT'S A IT'S A, YOU KNOW,
MOST ABUNDANT ELEMENT ON EARTH
AND SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE A LOT
OF FAMILIARITY WITH HIM. YEAH, I
DON'T NEED TO BE TUCKED INTO THE
TECHNOLOGY. I FOR IT. UM WHAT I
HAVE TO COME TO GRIPS WITH IS
THE SUPERSEDING OF LOCAL CONTROL
ON THE BASIS THAT THEY'RE
HOLDING THINGS UP, AND I WANT TO
KNOW WHY THEY'RE HOLDING THINGS
UP. DO YOU HAVE AN ANSWER OF
WHAT'S BEING WHAT THE PROCESS IS
RESTRICTED? AND THANK YOU. UH,
LOCALS REVIEW IS RESTRICTED TO
PURELY HEALTH AND SAFETY. AND
THAT WAS, UH UH, AS A RESULT OF
THE, UH, CENTER ARCHOS BILL, UM
AGAIN, I. I THINK, I. I WOULDN'T
DISAGREE WITH ANYTHING THAT THE
AUTHOR AND HAS HAS SAID WE'RE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE TECHNOLOGY AND
WE DON'T WANT TO BE BARRIERS. UH
I THINK THE WE HAVE TO TAKE A
STEP BACK. WE HAVE 18 PENDING
PERMITS IN THE STATE. WE HAVE
482 CITIES IN 58 COUNTIES. UM
THE THIS IS THE PASSAGE OF THIS
BILL IS NOT GOING TO SOMEHOW TIP
THE SCALES AND CREATE THIS
TSUNAMI OF FLOODGATES OF IN THE
PERMIT DESKS. UH UH. IT IS THE
IN OF CAPITAL. THERE'S A LACK OF
INTEREST. THERE'S SKEPTICISM
WITHIN DRIVERS, UH, I THINK THEY
WERE SUPPLYING CHAIN ISSUES
DURING THE PANDEMIC, WHERE
VEHICLES COULD NOT GET REFUELED
WITH EXISTING STATIONS. THE, UM
THERE'S ONE STATION HERE IN
SACRAMENTO SERVICE. KIND OF A
TRY MULTI COUNTY AREA. UH AND IT
WAS EMPTY AND PEOPLE HAD
REFUELING ISSUES AND CHALLENGES
AND TURN THOSE CARS IN, UH, WHEN
THE LEASE WAS UP, IT'S NOT A
LOCAL PERMITTING BARRIER. IT'S
UH, ALL THESE OTHER FACTORS. UM
AND LOCALS ARE LOOKING AT THE
COMPLEXITIES OF THE ENGINEERING
THESE TRANSPORTATION, THE
STORAGE ELECTORAL CODES. UH AND
SO WE ARE RESTRICTED ONLY TO
HEALTH. SO II, I I'M SORRY. I'M
JUST GONNA INTERRUPT THIS NOT
STOPPING THERE SO WE CAN DO TO
DO THE QUORUM SO OUR ASSISTANT
WOULD PLEASE ESTABLISH QUORUM.
SENATORS DURAZO, DURAZO PRESENT
SEYARTO SEYARTO PRESENT DOLLY
DOLLY PRESENT. GLAZER SKINNER!
WAHAB WAHAB PRESENT WIENER. WE
ARE PRESENT YOU HAVE A QUORUM.
THANK YOU. YES SENATOR. THAT WAS
CONTINUE. I APPRECIATE BOTH YOUR
EXPLANATIONS. UM IF A COMMUNITY
DOESN'T WANT IT. DOES THIS
REQUIRE THEM TO COME UP WITH A
PLAN TO HAVE IT? HERE'S THE
THING. WE'RE TALKING ABOUT 40
MILLION PEOPLE IN THE STATE,
CALIFORNIA CITIES UPON CITIES,
COUNTIES UPON COUNTIES, NOT
EVERY CITY IS GONNA JUMP INTO
ALLOWING IT. ALL WE'RE SAYING IS
THAT IF YOU HAVE AN APPLICATION,
DON'T PUT IT DOWN IN THE BOTTOM
OF THE BARREL. MAKE SURE THAT
YOU YOU YOU ATTEND TO IT, AND
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE SAYING. THEY
GO IN THE FRONT OF THE LINE WITH
ALL THE OTHER THINGS THAT ARE IN
THE FRONT OF THE LINE. THAT'S
WHAT I'M AFRAID. SO WE'RE NOT
ASKING TO PUT IT IN THE FRONT OF
THE LINE, BUT CERTAINLY GET IT
OUT FROM THE BOTTOM OF THE
BARREL. I GOT YOU AND THAT'S ALL
IT IS. IT'S A SIMPLE, SIMPLE
ASK. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. AND
THE FACT IS THAT THERE ARE
CITIES THAT WILL HAVE A
MORATORIUM, ALL RIGHT, AND IT IT
HAS BEEN NOTED THAT A CITY HAS
RECEIVED INFORMATION THAT
BECAUSE OF SENATE BILL, UH THAT
THAT I, UH SENATE BILL 1291.
THEY HAD TO LIFT THE MORATORIUM
BECAUSE THEY WERE IN VIOLATION
OF THE LAW. WE DON'T WANT ANYONE
TO BE IN VIOLATION OF THIS LAW,
EITHER. ALL IT SAYS IS AGAIN
OPEN THE DOORS TO PEOPLE WHO
WILL APPLY. MAKE IT EASIER
BECAUSE PARTNERSHIP UH,
INVESTMENT AND THAT'S WHY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS GIVEN
MONEY TO CALIFORNIA SO WE CAN
PROCEED WITH, UH, THAT ENERGY
SOURCE ZERO EMISSIONS. THIS IS
WHAT IT DOES. AND FOR A LOT OF
PEOPLE DON'T KNOW. YOU KNOW,
IT'S 18 WHEELERS RIGHT NOW ARE
RUNNING ON HYDROGEN AND PROBABLY
THE SIZE OF MY FINGERS TO HEAR
OF THE EMISSIONS WITH WATER
COMING OUT OF THE BACK END. I
MEAN, IS THE FUTURE OF
CALIFORNIA AND TO BE PART OF IT,
AND THIS IS ONE STEP THERE'S
GOING TO BE MORE AND MORE, BUT
THE INFRASTRUCTURE ITSELF NEEDS
TO HAPPEN WITHOUT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE. WE'RE NOT GONNA
BE ABLE TO MOVE THESE VEHICLES
OUT OF LONG BEACH AND SAN PEDRO
AND EVERYONE ELSE. SO WITH THAT,
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
AND I'LL TAKE THAT AS A
BEAUTIFUL CLOSING STATEMENT.
THANK YOU. UM AND I. I DO WANNA
COMMENT, UH, IN ADDITION TO OH,
GO AHEAD. I'M SORRY. NOT YET. I
WAS JUST GONNA SAY SOMETHING.
WHEN APPROPRIATE, OK, IT'S
APPROPRIATE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
, SENATOR. THANK YOU, I. I JUST
WANT TO SAY I DO SYMPATHIZE WITH
ONE OF YOUR, UH, ONE OF YOUR
REMARKS, AND THAT IS IF YOU'RE
GONNA GET MORE AND MORE
EXPEDITED, UH, REQUEST IF YOU'RE
GONNA HAVE TO, IF YOU'RE GONNA
BE REQUIRED TO MOVE THINGS MORE
EXPEDITIOUSLY FROM ONE SUBJECT
TO ANOTHER. THEN HOW DO YOU MAKE
THAT? HOW DO YOU MAKE THOSE
CHOICES? SO I THINK THAT'S A
VERY VALID POINT. AND I THINK
YOU SHOULD CONTINUE TO TALK TO
EACH OTHER ABOUT THAT CONCERN
BECAUSE WE WANT EXPEDITED TO
MEAN EXPEDITED, NOT EXPEDITED
WHEN THERE'S 10. OTHER THINGS
THAT HAVE TO BE EXPEDITED. UM,
SO WITH THAT WE HAVE AAA MOTION
BY SENATOR WAHAB AND, UH, WE
CALL THE ROLE CALL THE ROLE.
MOTION IS TO PASS. MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON TRANSPORTATION. SENATORS
DURAZO DURAZO, I SAY ARTO DOLLY
GLAZER! SKINNER WAHAB WAHAB IY
WIENER. WINNER. I 3 TO 0. WILL
HOLD ON. OR PUT IT ON CALL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THANK YOU, SENATOR CHULETA.
WE'RE GOING ON NOW. THING. WE
ALL. WAS HE YEAH. OK UH, WE'RE
GONNA GO NOW WE'RE GONNA GO BACK
TO OR WE'RE RIGHT IN. IN THE
RIGHT ORDER, SENATOR WEINER. YOU
ARE PRESENTING SB 937. DO THE
CONSENT. OH, AM SORRY, SENATOR
WEINER. BEFORE YOU START, WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE UP THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. MOTION IS ADOPTED THE
CONSENT CALENDAR SENATOR ZAZO
DURAZO, I SAY ARTO SEAR I DOLLY
GLAZER! SKINNER WAHAB! WAHAB I
WIENER WIN! I'M 40 0. THANK YOU.
OK NOW, SENATOR WEINER MOVE WITH
S¼ B 937. GREAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MADAM CHAIR. FIRST OF ALL
I WANT TO REALLY THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR AND YOUR, UH, STAFF
FOR WORKING WITH US ON THIS BILL
. WE MADE SOME AMENDMENTS, UH,
PUT IN THE PRINT BEFORE THE
WORKING WITH YOUR COMMITTEE AND
ALSO WITH VARIOUS, UH
STAKEHOLDERS, INCLUDING SOME OF
THE WATER DISTRICTS, PARK
DISTRICTS, ET CETERA. UM AND
THEN WE HAVE. ADDITIONALLY UM,
WORKED ON ADDITIONAL AMENDMENTS
IN LIEU OF THE AMENDMENTS IN THE
ANALYSIS. I JUST WANNA I KNOW
THAT, UH, THE LANGUAGE HAS BEEN
DISTRIBUTED. I JUST WANT TO GO
THROUGH THEM, SO IT'S ON THE
RECORD, AND I'M VERY
APPRECIATIVE FOR THE CHAIRS. UH,
ENGAGEMENT. UM SO FOR THE, UM
BOTH THE FEE DEFERRALS AND THE
ENTITLEMENT EXTENSION. THE
FOLLOWING PROJECTS WOULD BE
ELIGIBLE, UM, PROJECTS THAT ARE,
UM 100% AFFORDABLE HOUSING. UH,
PROJECTS PROJECTS SUBJECT TO, UH
, AN ENTITLEMENT UNDER S¼ P 35.
FOR S¼ P 42 THREE, WHICH IS THE
SUCCESSOR LAW, A B 2011 STATE
AND CITY BONUS LAW. S¼ B FOUR S¼
B TWO WITH THE, UM LOW BARRIER
NAVIGATION CENTERS OR ANY
PROJECT, UM GLOBALLY THAT IS 10
UNITS OR LESS SO SMALL PROJECTS.
UM UH, IN ADDITION, THERE ARE
AMENDMENTS. UH, THAT, UM THAT
WERE A AGREEING TO AND THEY'RE
THEY'RE JUST A CAVEAT FOR
ONGOING WORK WITH THE COMMITTEE,
BUT, UM, AMENDMENTS THAT WERE
REQUESTED BY LOCAL GOVERNMENT
GROUPS. UM RELATING TO, UH,
UTILITY SERVICE FEES, UM,
CLARIFYING THAT CONNECTION AND
CAPACITY CHARGES CAN BE CHARGED
AT THE TIME OF APPLICATION TO
RESTORE THE ABILITY FOR LOCAL
AGENCIES TO CHARGE FEES EARLIER
FOR EXPENDITURES PREVIOUSLY MADE
IN OTHER WORDS, IF THEY ARE
INCURRING ONGOING EXPENSES THAT
WOULD BE ALLOWED TO BE COLLECTED
. UM EARLIER, UM ONE CAVEAT
THERE THAT UM UH, WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THE ON. UM IS THAT
IF IT IS A, UM, LONG RANGE, UH
PLAN WITHOUT A CONSTRUCTION
SCHEDULE. THEY'RE NOT REALLY
PAYING THE MONEY RIGHT NOW. AND
SO, UM, WE'D LIKE TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE COMMITTEE. UM ON
ON THAT ISSUE. I THINK WE SORT
OF RAN OUT OF TIME. UH UH,
BEFORE TODAY'S HEARING, UM, AN
AMENDMENT TO RESTORE LANGUAGE,
ALLOWING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
REQUIRE THE POSTING OF A
PERFORMANCE BOND OR A LETTER OF
CREDIT. FOR PROJECTS THAT ARE AT
LEAST 49% AFFORDABLE. UM AND
AGAIN, WE RAN OUT OF TIME
DISCUSSING THAT WE WANT TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE ON THAT. BUT WE ARE,
UM, AGREEING FOR THAT TO GO INTO
THE BILL, UM, TO RESTORE
LANGUAGE, ALLOWING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO REQUIRE
DEVELOPERS TO ENTER INTO A
CONTRACT WITH THE ABILITY TO
AUTHORIZE AN OFFICER TO APPROVE
OR AND EXECUTE CONTRACTS AND
POST A MODEL FORM OF CONTRA ON
WEBSITE AND THE CLARIFY THAT IF
A LOCAL AGENCY DOES NOT ISSUE
CERTIFICATES OF OCCUPANCY. FINAL
INSPECTION SERVES AS A
CERTIFICATE OF ACCURACY. SO
THOSE ARE THE, UM THE AMENDMENTS
HAVE AGREED TO THOSE THOSE TWO
AREAS. I APPRECIATE THE CHAIR'S
WILLINGNESS TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH US. WE OF COURSE, WILL MAKE
NÓ AMENDMENTS WITHOUT THE SIGN
OFF, UH, OF THE CHAIR GOING
FORWARD, UM, IN THOSE AREAS, SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH. UM OK WITH
ALL THAT SAID, UH, THIS BILL, UM
DOES, UH, TWO THINGS. UH, FIRST
OF ALL, UH AND, UH FOR, UH,
PROJECTS. UH, THAT RECEIVED
THEIR ENTITLEMENT. UH AT SOME
POINT BETWEEN JANUARY 1ST 2024
OR EXCUSE ME FOR PROJECTS WHERE
THEY'RE ENTITLEMENT IS SET TO
EXPIRE BETWEEN JANUARY 1ST 2024
AND DECEMBER 31ST 2025. IT WILL
EXTEND THOSE ENTITLEMENTS BY 24
MONTHS. WE'RE IN A PERIOD RIGHT
NOW WHERE WE HAVE PROJECTS THAT
HAVE BEEN FULLY ENTITLED GONE
THROUGH THE PROCESS INTEREST
RATE. ARE EXTREMELY HIGH RIGHT
NOW, AND THERE ARE PROJECTS THAT
ARE GETTING FROZEN BECAUSE THE
FINANCING DOESN'T WORK WITH THE
HIGH INTEREST RATES. THIS WILL
JUST CREATE SOME MORE BREATHING
ROOM, UH FOR THEM, SO THESE
PROJECTS DO NOT FALL APART THE
OTHER PIECE OF THE BILL? UM, IT,
UH, FOR CERTAIN TYPES OF IMPACT
FEES. ALLOWS PAYMENT OF THEM AT
THE ISSUANCE OF CERTIFICATE OF
OCCUPANCY, AS OPPOSED TO AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE PROJECT. UH WE
KNOW THAT AND IT WAS ACTUALLY
JUST A VERY, UM SOBERING ARTICLE
IN THE LOS ANGELES TIMES TODAY.
UM ABOUT THE, UH, DECELERATION
OF CERTAIN KINDS OF HOUSING
PRODUCTION. UH, BECAUSE OF BOTH
HIGH END NOT JUST HIGH INTEREST
RATES, BUT ALSO THE SIGNIFICANT
ESCALATION OF CONSTRUCTION COSTS
. UH AND SO THE CHANGE IN THE
TIMING OF THE PAYMENT OF THESE
PARTICULAR FEES, UH, WILL HELP
PROJECTS ACTUALLY HAPPEN. I DO
WANNA STRESS THAT IF, UM IF A
DEVELOPER PAYS IMPACT FEES AND
THE PROJECT THEN DOESN'T HAPPEN
BE, FOR EXAMPLE, IT BECOMES
INFEASIBLE. CITIES ARE REQUIRED
TO REIMBURSE, UH, THOSE FEES.
SO, FOR EXAMPLE, MY
UNDERSTANDING IS RIGHT NOW, UH,
THAT SOME CITIES ARE HOLDING
FEES IN ESCROW BECAUSE OTHERWISE
IT COULD BE LIABLE FOR REPAYMENT
AND THEY'VE ALREADY EXPENDED THE
FEES. SO THIS IS, UH, I THINK A
GOOD, UM, PRO HOUSING APPROACH.
SO UH, THAT IS, UH, THE BILL
AGAIN. I'M VERY APPRECIATIVE OF
THE CHAIR'S ENGAGEMENT AND WORK
WITH US. AND WITH ME HERE, UH
TO, UH, TESTIFY, OR, UH, GRACI.
CASTILLO KRINGS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING CONSORTIUM,
ONE OF OUR CO SPONSORS, AND
MOHAMMED, UM ALAM DIÆN, A POLICY
ASSOCIATE WITH UC BERKELEY
TURNER CENTER FOR HOUSING
INNOVATION. GOOD MORNING, MADAM
èC TO THE HEARING. THANK YOU,
SENATOR. GOOD MORNING, MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS GRACIA LÀ
CASILLO CRES. I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
CONSORTIUM AND WANTED TO ECHO
THE SENATOR'S COMMENTS REALLY
APPRECIATE THE NUMEROUS HOURS
THAT YOU AND YOUR STAFF HAVE
SPENT ON THE BILL. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO ADDITIONAL
CONVERSATIONS. UH, THE HOUSING
CONSORTIUM IS A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION THAT ADVOCATES FOR
HOUSING THAT IS AFFORDABLE TO
BOTH LOW INCOME AND MODERATE
HOUSEHOLDS. EVERY MEMBER OF THIS
COMMITTEE IS VERY AWARE OF THE
HOUSING SHORTAGE AND THE CRISIS
THAT THAT IS CREATING FOR A LOT
OF OUR FAMILIES AND A LOT OF
YEARS THAT ARE ENDING UP ON THE
STREETS. THE PROBLEM IS FURTHER
COMPOUNDED BY THE LACK OF
SUSTAINABLE. UM A SUSTAINABLE
FUNDING SOURCE. AND CONSIDERING
THIS REALITY, THE HOUSING
COMMUNITY IS SEARCHING FOR
POLICY SOLUTIONS THAT CAN HELP
US KIND OF WEATHER THIS UPCOMING
STORM. S¼ B 937 SEEKS TO ADD
ANOTHER TOOL INTO THE TOOL BELT
AND HELP ADDRESS THE PROBLEM. S¼
P 937 DOES NOT PREVENT LOCALS
FREEZE FROM BEING PREVENTED FROM
BEING LEVIED. THEY SIMPLY CHANGE
WHEN THESE FEES ARE COLLECTED.
THIS CHANGE HELPS, UH, KEEP
FUNDING FLOWING FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WHILE AT THE SAME
TIME ENSURING THAT PROJECTS
PENCIL OUT. WHEN IMPACT FEES ARE
COLLECTED AT THE EARLY STAGES OF
DEVELOPMENT. THAT IS WHEN THE
ACTUAL BORROWING COSTS ARE THE
MOST EXPENSIVE SIMPLY BECAUSE
THE CONSTRUCTION HAS NOT
STARTED. BANKS DON'T LEND AT
THAT POINT. JUST TO QUOTE A
PAPER. UM, THAT WAS ISSUED BY U
èC L A LEWIS CENTER. THEY FOUND
THAT ASSESSING FEES AT EARLIER
STAGES CAN DO REAL HARM BY
DETERRING HOUSING PRODUCTION. IT
FURTHER WENT ON TO SAY THAT FEE
A FERAL PROGRAMS CAN EFFICIENTLY
REDUCE COST AND INCREASE THE
VIABILITY OF HOUSING PRODUCTION.
AND THEY CAN DO SO WITHOUT
ASKING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
FORFEIT REVENUE. THIS WAS BASED
ON LOOKING AT THE L, A HOUSING
PROGRAM, WHICH ACTUALLY DIFFERS
FEES SO AT THE TIME WHEN IT'S
UNCLEAR IF THERE IS GOING TO BE
A HOUSING BOND ON NOVEMBER ON A
TIME WHEN THE GOVERNOR IS
PROPOSING TO ELIMINATE ALL
GENERAL FUND AND HOUSING LOOKING
FOR PO SOLUTIONS CAN REALLY THAT
CAN HELP BRING COSTS DOWN ARE
CRUCIAL AND CRITICAL. THIS IS
ONE OF THE REASONS WE ARE NOT
JUST A SUPPORTER, BUT AS A
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL, AND FOR
THOSE REASONS WE ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU, CHAIR, DERA AND
DISTINGUISHED MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS YOU THIS MORNING
REGARDING SENATE BILL NINE,
THREE SEVEN. MY NAME IS MOHAMMED
AL DIÆN, AND I SERVE AS THE
POLICY ASSOCIATE FOR U èC
BERKELEY'S TURNER CENTER FOR
HOUSING INNOVATION. THE TURNER
CENTER IS A RESEARCH CENTER.
FOCUSED ON A RANGE OF HOUSING
ISSUES FROM LAND USE TO ZONING
REFORM TO ADDRESSING
HOMELESSNESS TO EXPLORING THE
NEXUS BETWEEN CLIMATE CHANGE AND
HOUSING. IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT MY TESTIMONY IS NOT
INTENDED TO EXPRESS A STANCE ON
THIS BILL. INSTEAD MY AIM IS TO
SHARE INSIGHTS BASED ON OUR
RESEARCH ON THE SUBJECT OF
IMPACT FEES. OVER THE PAST NINE
YEARS, THE TURNER CENTER HAS
RELEASED MULTIPLE RESEARCH
PAPERS THAT DELVE INTO THE
EFFECTS OF IMPACT FEES ON
HOUSING PROJECTS. THESE FEES,
WHICH ARE LEVIED BY CITIES ON
NEW HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS, COVER
MY RATE OF MUNICIPAL COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE INCREASED
DEMAND AND PUBLIC FACILITIES AND
INFRASTRUCTURE. IT'S WORTH
HIGHLIGHTING THAT THESE FEES ARE
PARTICULARLY STEEP. IN
CALIFORNIA, WHERE THE LEGACIES
OF LIMITED OPTIONS FOR MUNICIPAL
REVENUE HAVE DRIVEN THE AVERAGE
IMPACT FEE TO BE ALMOST TRIPLE
THE NATIONAL AVERAGE. I'LL
PRESENT FINDINGS FROM JUST TWO
OF THESE RESEARCH PAPERS TODAY.
AS IT RELATES TO S¼ P NINE,
THREE SEVEN. IT'S WORTH NOTING
THAT OUR RESEARCH RESIDENTIAL
IMPACT FEES IN CALIFORNIA DID
INDEED FIND THAT A LARGE
MAJORITY OF LOCALITIES IMPOSED
IMPACT FEES AT THE TIME OF
BUILDING PERMIT SUBMISSION. ONLY
A QUARTER OF JURISDICTIONS. WE
STUDIED DEFERRED IMPACT FEES TO
FINAL INSPECTION OR CERTIFICATE
OF OCCUPANCY. IN TERMS OF
UNDERSTANDING THE BENEFICIAL
IMPACT TO MEETING THE STATE'S
HOUSING GOALS FROM DEFERRING
FEES. IT IS NOT POSSIBLE TO GIVE
A DEFINITIVE ANSWER, HOWEVER, IT
IS LIKELY MATERIALLY BENEFICIAL,
PARTICULARLY IN THE CURRENT
INTEREST RATE ENVIRONMENT. FIVE
MONTHS AGO, WE RELEASED MAKING A
PENCIL THE MATH BEHIND HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT WHERE WE ANALYZE
PROTOTYPICAL MULTIFAMILY
PROPERTIES AND THREE MAJOR
CALIFORNIA MARKETS. WE THEN
CONDUCTED A FINANCIAL ANALYSIS
OF THE FEASIBILITY OF BUILDING
FIVE STORIES OVER ONE STORY OF
RETAIL, A VERY COMMON
MULTIFAMILY DEVELOPMENT TYPE. 00
SORRY, AND EVERY MARKET EXAMINED
. WE FOUND THAT THESE, UM
APARTMENT STRUCTURES DO NOT
PENCIL, MEANING THAT THEY ARE
NOT FINANCIALLY FEASIBLE UNDER
CURRENT MARKET CONDITIONS. USING
THIS MODELING, WE WERE ABLE TO
ASSESS THE IMPACT OF DEFERRING
IMPACT FEES FROM THE DATE WHEN
THE FIRST BUILDING PERMIT IS
PULLED TO THE DATE OF
CERTIFICATE OF OCCUPANCY. WE
FOUND THAT THE POSTPONE IT OF
FEES SAVES ABOUT $7000 PER UNIT,
WHICH VARIES GREATLY BASED ON
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS. UM, FEE
STRUCTURE. A BETTER ESTIMATION
WOULD BE THAT THE DEFERRAL FEES
SAVE ABOUT 1% OF TOTAL UNIT OF
TOTAL DEVELOPMENT COSTS. I'M
SORRY. YEAH. WHILE 1% MAY SEEM
SMALL, IT WOULD SET THE PROJECTS
INTO FEASIBILITY AND HENCE ALLOW
, UM, HOUSING TO BEGIN
CONSTRUCTION THAT WOULD
OTHERWISE HAPPEN ABSENT OF THIS
CHANGE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. APPRECIATE
IT. UM DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF S¼ B
937. PLEASE COME FORWARD. GIVE
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION. GOOD MORNING, REBECCA
MARCUS ON BEHALF OF LEADING AGE,
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING BLACK ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN COUNCIL
OF ENGINEERING COMPANIES AND
SUPPORT GOOD MORNING, CORNELIUS
BURKE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION.
WE ARE CALIFORNIA'S HOME
BUILDERS. WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS. DAVID
AZEVEDO, A RP, CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. COREY SMITH HOUSING
ACTION COALITION, ONE OF THE CO
SPONSORS IN SUPPORT. BROOKE
PRITCHARD, ONE OF THE OTHER CO
SPONSORS ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA, YB. SHAME IS SCARY.
UM HERE WITH LIGHTHOUSE PUBLIC
AFFAIRS ON BEHALF. OF SPUR SAND
HILL PROPERTIES. UM, EXCUSE ME.
SORRY. I LOST IT. UM BUILD CASA
FIELDS AND HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
OF CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, CHRIS ROSA ON BEHALF OF
THE SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP
GROUP IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS SO AND MADDEN AT W
STRATEGIES ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY BUILDERS
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. DO WE
HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION? WE HAVE, YOU CAN
STEP UP. YOU CAN HAVE TWO TWO
MINUTES EACH. IF YOU WANT IT,
I'LL BE VERY QUICK, UH, CHRIS
ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES. WE DIDN'T HAVE A
POSITION. WE HAD CONCERNS. THE
RECENT AUTHORS AMENDMENTS THIS
WEEK DID APPEAR TO ADDRESS OUR
CONCERNS. SO JUST WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR AND STAFF THE
COMMITTEE FOR AND THE SPONSORS
FOR WORKING WITH US. THANK YOU.
WE'LL TAKE THE TWO PRINCIPAL
WITNESSES. YES, OK. GO AHEAD AND
TWO MINUTES, PLEASE. THANK YOU,
MADAM. CHAIR ANTHONY TANNEHILL
WITH CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION. WE
REPRESENT UH ALL MANNER OF LOCAL
SERVICES FROM FIRE PROTECTION
AND FLOOD PROTECTION AND HEALTH
CARE AND EVERYTHING IN BETWEEN.
AND OUR POSITION WAS A IS A
POSING LESS AMENDED. UM AND I
JUST REALLY WANTED TO TAKE THE
TIME TO THINK THE COMMITTEE AND
THEIR STAFF THE AUTHOR. STAFF
AND THE PROPONENTS WHO HAD AN
OPEN DOOR POLICY. AND UH, WE'VE,
UH UH, WE'RE ALL FAST FRIENDS
NOW, AND I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE, UH THE, UH, THE WORK AND
THE EFFORT THAT GOES INTO IT.
AND, UM, JUST WANNA REMIND THE
COMMITTEE AND THE STAKEHOLDERS
THAT IN ORDER TO HAVE THE
COMMUNITIES BUILT THAT WE WANT.
IT HAS TO COME WITH THE SERVICES
AND WE WANT TO PROVIDE THEM AND
SO I DO APPRECIATE THE
THOUGHTFULNESS THAT'S GOING INTO
IT. WE LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING IT
IN PRINT AND TAKING IT BACK TO
OUR MEMBERS AND GOING FROM THERE
. OK, THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. OK ANYONE ELSE IN
? UH OPPOSITION TO S¼ B 937.
GOOD MORNING, ALYSSA. SO HØI
WITH THE RUNNING PUBLIC POLICY
GROUP ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
RECREATION AND PARK SERVICES,
WANTED TO THANK THE MEMBER AND
THE MEMBERS, STAFF AND COMMITTEE
STAFF WERE ABLE TO COME OFF OF
OUR OPPOSING UNLESS A POSITION
BASED ON THE AMENDMENTS IN
PRINT. ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
BELMONT. I THINK WE MIGHT END UP
BEING ABLE TO BE OK, BUT LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING THE AMENDMENTS
IN PRINT THAT YOU MENTIONED
TODAY AND REALLY THINK THE WORK
OF THE COMMITTEE AND THE AUTHOR
AND, UM, HOPE TO GET THERE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. DANIEL
BLASTER, WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION,
REPRESENTING WATER AND PUBLICLY
OWNED ELECTRIC UTILITIES WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR AND THE
COMMITTEE AS WELL WITH THE
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE IN PRINT NOW
AND THE PROPOSED COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. I BELIEVE THAT WILL
ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS. SO JUST
WANNA THANK THE COMMITTEE AND
THE AUTHOR FOR YOUR EFFORTS.
THANK YOU. SPENCER SACKS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SANITATION
AGENCIES. I'D LIKE TO, UH, ECHO
ECHO THE PREVIOUS COMMENTS. WE
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS AND
THE WORK THAT'S GONE IN AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR AND THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MARK NEWBERGER, CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES ALSO
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE WORK OF
THE COMMITTEE AS WELL AS THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE ON AMENDMENTS.
WE ARE CURRENTLY HAVE AN OPPOSED
LESS AMENDED POSITION, BUT WE
LOOK FORWARD TO REVIEWING THE
AMENDMENTS AND REASSESSING
ACCORDINGLY. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS BRADY
GARDEN ON BEHALF OF THE LEAGUE
OF CALIFORNIA CITIES. WE ALSO
HAVE AN OPPO UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION. BUT GIVEN THE
AMENDMENTS WE REVIEWING THEM
WHEN THEY'RE IN PRINT AND IN
HOPES OF REMOVING IT, SO I
WANTED TO THANK THE CHAIR AND
THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE FOR THEIR
CONTINUED CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
THAT, AND WE'LL LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING IT THROUGH. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS, LAUREN DE
VALENCIA, REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN PLANNING ASSOCIATION,
WOULD ECHO THE REALLY BIG
APPRECIATION FOR ALL THE WORK
THAT'S GONE INTO THIS. WE DON'T
HAVE A FORMAL POSITION ON THE
BILL, BUT DID HAVE SOME
TECHNICAL CONCERNS AND
APPRECIATE THE SPONSORS, THE
AUTHOR AND THE COMMITTEE'S WORK
ON THIS AND WE WILL BE REMOVING.
WE DIDN'T DIDN'T HAVE
OPPOSITION. SORRY WE WILL BE
REMOVING ANY CONCERNS AND MOVE
TO NEUTRAL. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING. TRACY RYAN,
RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVE OF
CALIFORNIA. UM, LIKEWISE, WE DID
NOT HAVE A FORMAL POSITION. UM,
WE DO APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK OF
THE AUTHOR, THE AUTHOR STAFF THE
COMMITTEE STAFF, UM AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING ON THE BILL.
AS IT MOVES FORWARD. WE DO HAVE
SOME CONCERNS THAT WE WANT TO
CONTINUE TO WORK OUT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. OK NÓ MORE. UM NÓ ONE
ELSE IN OPPOSITION. BRING IT TO
THE MEMBERS. THAT WAS THE BEST
OPPOSITION I'VE EVER HAD. THAT
TOOK A LOT OF WORK. YES SENATOR.
AND HERE'S THE CHERRY ON TOP. I
UH, PLANET SPORT. YOUR BILL, UH,
WITH THE AMENDMENT, ESPECIALLY,
UH, THAT ALLOWS, UH FOR LOCAL
AGENCIES IF THEY'RE MID PROJECT
AND NEED THE MONEY TO FINISH THE
PROJECT THAT IT GOES IN, UH,
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR PEOPLE TO
UNDERSTAND THAT, UM, WHEN MONEY
IS COLLECTED IT, ACTUALLY, THE
MITIGATION MONEY GOES INTO A POT
UNTIL THEY HAVE ENOUGH FROM ALL
THE DIFFERENT PROJECTS TO BUILD
THAT AMENITY AND SO WHETHER IT
GOES IN INTO THE FRONT OR GOES
IN THE BACK. THAT BIG OF A DEAL
UNLESS THEY'RE MID PROJECT. AND
SO YOUR AMENDMENTS TOOK CARE OF
THAT. ONLY THAT ONE CONCERN, UM
AND THE FINANCING ISSUE IS A BIG
DEAL RIGHT NOW, ESPECIALLY FOR
ANY PROJECTS UP FRONT. AND YEAH,
IT'S KIND OF HARD TO GET ALL THE
MITIGATION MONEY FINANCED, UH,
WHEN YOU DON'T EVEN HAVE
SOMETHING ON THE GROUND FOR
COLLATERAL, AND, UH SO, UH, WITH
THAT, UH, STATED, APPRECIATE ALL
THE WORK YOU DID TO TRY TO
SMOOTH OUT SOME OF THE ROUGH
EDGES AND, UH AND I'LL BE
SUPPORTING YOUR TODAY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. OK WELL, I ALSO
WANNA THANK THE AUTHOR. UM OUR
COMMITTEE WORKED VERY, VERY HARD
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. JONATHAN.
UM I DON'T KNOW IF YOU'RE
SUPPOSED TO DO THAT. SHOUT OUT
YOUR YOUR STAFF BUT WHO WORKED
VERY HARD AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT AND THANK THE
AUTHOR, UH, FOR WORKING ON WITH
THE COMMITTEE ON THESE, UH,
AMENDMENTS, UM, LIMITING THE
TYPES OF PROJECTS THAT WILL
RECEIVE THE FEED DEFERRALS AND,
UH, ENTITLEMENT EXTENSIONS. UM
AND THOSE YOU KNOW TO KIND OF
PROJECTS THAT WILL BRING REAL
AFFORDABILITY. UM OUR HOUSING.
WE ALL KNOW THERE IS AN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AFFORDABILITY
CRISIS, UH, AND HELPING
DEVELOPERS MAKE THEIR PROJECTS
PENCIL OUT IMPORTANT, BUT WE
ALSO KNOW THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
NEED TO BE ABLE TO FINANCE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE AS WE BUILD OUT
THAT, UM, HOUSING AND THEY NEED
TO BE ABLE TO MITIGATE THE
IMPACTS OF THAT DEVELOPMENT IN
OUR COMMUNITIES. UM THEY NEED
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS NEED THE
CERTAINTY THAT THEY CAN COLLECT
IMPACT FEE REVENUE. IN A TIMELY
FASHION. UM AND THE AMENDMENTS
ARE RESTORED THEIR ABILITY TO
CONTRACT WITH DEVELOPERS TO
REPAY THAT REVENUE WILL HELP
GUARANTEE. UH THEY RECEIVE THIS,
UH, REVENUE THAT THEY VERY MUCH.
I DON'T THINK WE DISAGREE, UH,
THAT THE INFRASTRUCTURE IS
NEEDED FOR THE HOUSING. WE NEED
THE HOUSING DONE NOW, SO WE NEED
TO BE ABLE TO WATCH OUT FOR
THOSE. SO WITH THE AMENDMENTS.
UM I WILL SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY
AND URGE ALSO SUPPORT FROM MY
COLLEAGUES. UM, WITH THAT. ANY
CLOSING REMARKS AFTER SUCH A
BEAUTIFUL PRESENTATION BY YOUR
OPPOSITION. FIRST OF ALL, I WANT
TO REITERATE MY THANKS TO THE
CHAIR AND TO THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR WORKING SO DILIGENTLY WITH
US, AND I WANT TO THANK ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS WHO REALLY WORKED
IN GOOD FAITH, UH, WITH US, AND
I FEEL GOOD ABOUT WHERE THE BILL
IS, UH, LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUED WORK AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I VOTE.
NÓ OTHER MOTION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. OK MOTION IS MOVED BY
SENATOR SEYARTO. MOTION IS TO
PASS A CEMENTED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON HOUSING SENATORS. DURAZO
DURAZO, I SAY ARTO SEAR I DOLLY
GLAZER SKINNER! WAHAB WAHAB! I
WIENER. I 40 SHE IS. I WAS
THINKING SHE MIGHT HAVE PIPED IN
HER. THAT THE WE'RE HOLDING, PUT
ON. HOLD ON. CALL ON CALL, OK?
MOTION ON SENATOR STERN. WE'RE
GOING TO VOTE ON. WE SEE
MOTIONLESS. NÓ. OK UH, SENATOR
GARDO YOU'LL BE PRESENTING ON S¼
P 955. YES. HELLO THERE. OK?
WELL FIRST. I KNOW A LOT OF
PEOPLE SAY THIS IS A COURTESY
FIRST, BUT I WANNA THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF BECAUSE YOU GUYS
HAVE WORKED WITH MY STAFF, UH,
TO TRY TO HELP CRAFT THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT WENT FROM AN IDEA TO
A, UH, A RIGHT. I THINK A REALLY
GOOD BILL THAT'LL BE HELPFUL,
UH, FOR COMMUNITIES. SO, UM
CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO SUFFER
FROM INADEQUATE INFRASTRUCTURE
FUNDING, AND IT LEADS TO UNSAFE
CONDITIONS FOR A LOT OF OUR
RESIDENTS. UH, THIS BILL AIMS TO
SUPPORT OUR CITIES AND COUNTIES
IN COMPLETING VITAL
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS ON TIME
BY CREATING A GAP FUND. AND A
NEW, WHICH WOULD BE A NEW GRANT.
BUT IT'S A LITTLE DIFFERENT THAN
THE ONES THAT ARE CURRENTLY
AROUND. AND UH AND IT CAN BE, UM
, FUNDED LET ANNUALLY BY THE
LEGISLATURE, BUT THIS PARTICULAR
BILL JUST CREATES THE FUND
ITSELF. THE POT FOR IT DOESN'T
MEAN IT'S GETTING FUNDED RIGHT
NOW. UH, THE GAP FUND'S PURPOSE
IS TO CLOSE THAT LAST BIT OF
FUNDING THAT ALWAYS HAPPENS. OR
THAT HAPPENS A LOT, ESPECIALLY
TO, UH, COMMUNITIES THAT ARE IN,
UH MORE RURAL AREAS LIKE
COACHELLA VALLEY FOR ME AND SOME
OF OUR OTHER COMMUNITIES WHERE
THEY'VE GONE THROUGH THE
PROCESS. THEY'VE GOT ALL THEIR
FUNDING. THEY GET TO THE END
AFTER GETTING ALL THIS STUFF
DONE, AND NOW THE COST IS
ESCALATED. ANOTHER 1 TO 2 OR
THREE MILLION DOLLARS. UH, THIS
HAS HAPPENED IN MY DISTRICT A
FEW TIMES. AND SOMETIMES WE PLUG
THAT GAP WITH OUR DISTRICT ASKS,
BUT MORE THAN NOT, IT DOES NOT
HAPPEN. UM AND SO THEY WAIT AND
GUESS WHAT HAPPENS. THE COSTS
ESCALATE, WHICH PUTS PRESSURE ON
WHAT WE WERE JUST TALKING ABOUT
BEFORE. IT MAKES THE, UH, THE,
UM, MITIGATION FEES GO UP MORE
SO WE'RE TRYING TO STOP THE
BLEEDING WITH THIS. THAT'S WHAT
THIS IS TRYING TO DO. SO UH,
DENYING THESE PROJECTS
INEVITABLY INCREASES COSTS OVER
TIME DUE TO FACTORS LIKE
INFLATION. LABOR AND MATERIALS.
THE BILL IS THE LAST RESORT FOR
ITS DESIGN TO BE THE LAST RESORT
FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. UH TO
FUND A PROJECT THAT WOULD
OTHERWISE WOULD HAVE BEEN FUNDED
BUT DUE UNFORESEEN
CIRCUMSTANCES, COSTS INCREASED.
UH, WE ALL KNOW HOW DIFFICULT
AND FRUSTRATING THE PROCESS OF
SUBMITTING DISTRICT BUDGET
REQUESTS, WHICH THEN GET DENIED.
AND SO THIS WILL HELP ALLEVIATE
SOME OF THAT BY ALLOWING M
MUNICIPALITIES TO APPLY FOR A
GRANT DIRECTLY FROM THIS FUND
OVERSEEN BY THE OFFICE OF
PLANNING AND RESEARCH. S¼ B 955
WILL ESTABLISH THE GAP FUND WITH
THE INTENT OF ANNUAL FUNDING FOR
THE LEGISLATURE THAT PROVIDES A
RELIABLE MONETARY SOURCE FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA TO FURTHER
DISCUSS THIS BILL, I HAVE WITH
ME NICOLE WEDMAN FROM ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF ONTARIO, SO I
WOULD GO AHEAD. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WELCOME. AND YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR
NICOLE ELMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF ONTARIO IN SUPPORT OF S¼
B 955 S¼ B 955 WILL PROVIDE AN
ADDITIONAL FUNDING MECHANISM FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS, WHICH
IS A VERY HIGH PRIORITY FOR
ONTARIO. ONTARIO HAS NUMEROUS
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS UNDERWAY
IN HAS IDENTIFIED APPROXIMATELY
1.2 BILLION IN UNFUNDED
INFRASTRUCTURE AND NEIGHBORHOOD
IMPROVEMENT PROJECTS THAT OVER
TIME WILL BECOME MORE EXPENSIVE
TO ADDRESS ALL OF THESE PROJECTS
RANGE FROM WATER RECLAMATION TO
BROADBAND CONNECTIONS AND HAVE
ONLY INCREASED IN THEIR COSTS
OVER THE YEARS. THE CYCLE OF
PLANNING, FUNDING LICENSING AND
FINALLY APPROVING SHOVEL READY
PROJECTS HAS LED TO MANY
PROJECTS SUDDENLY RISING IN
COSTS DUE TO LONGER THAN
EXPECTED PROCESSES AND SUDDEN
ECONOMIC IMPACTS. THESE IMPACTS
HAVE RAISED THE COST OF THESE
PROJECTS BEYOND THE MEANS OF THE
CITY OF ONTARIO AND CREATED A
NON ACHIEVABLE FINANCIAL GOAL.
S¼ B 955 WILL ASSIST IN CLOSING
THE LAST GAP IN UNEXPECTED
FUNDING AND INCORPORATE THESE
GENERATIONAL INVESTMENTS IN THE
COMMUNITY, INCREASING THE SAFETY
AND WELL BEING OF ONTARIO
RESIDENTS. THEREFORE ONTARIO
URGES AN I VOTE ON THE MEASURE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
UM MORE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
S¼ B 955. GOOD MORNING, MADAM
CHAIR DAMON CONKLIN ON BEHALF OF
THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES
AS WELL AS UH, THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MATT ROMAN HERE ON BEHALF OF
EASTERN MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT
HERE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. UH, NÓ.
MORE IN, UH, WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. UH, WE HAVE ANYBODY IN
OPPOSITION. NÓ SEE. AIN'T NOBODY
IN OPPOSITION. UH, COME TO THE
MEMBERS. ANY COMMENTS BY OUR
MEMBERS? NÓ NONE. OK? I THINK
WE'RE WE'RE GOOD. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO HAVE SOME CLOSING? I SIMPLY
ASKED FOR AN I I'M SORRY. JUST
ONE MORE THING. UM, IF YOU ARE
WILLING TO TAKE THE AMENDMENTS,
YES, I I'M WE AGREED TO THE
AMENDMENTS AND ARE GOING TO BE
TAKING THE AMENDMENTS. THANK
YOU. OK, GREAT. THANK YOU. OK,
UM, READY TO GO WITH OUR CLOSING
CLOSING REMARKS. MY CLOSING
REMARKS ARE I SIMPLY ASKED FOR
AN I VOTE. THAT'S A GREAT BILL.
EMOTION AND. NOW MOVED WITH
AMEND BY AS AMENDED. OK WE HAVE
A MOTION BY SENATOR SKINNER. YOU
PASS THOSE AMENDED TO THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
SENATORS DURAZO DURAZO, I SAY
ARTO, I SE ARTO, A DOLLY GLACIER
SKINNER HØI SKINNER, I WAHAB
WAHAB, I WIENER WINNER. I FIGHT
A ZERO THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THAT DOESN'T STAY OPEN.
SO, UM S¼ B 955 WILL STAY ON
CALL. STAY OPEN ON CALL. OK, I.
I NEED A MOTION. OH, SENATOR. ON
S¼ 1251. SENATOR STERN CAN I
HAVE A MOTION? OK? CAN WE TO THE
ROLE. MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON ENERGY, UTILITIES
AND COMMUNICATIONS. SENATORS
DURAZO DURAZO, I èC ARTO SEAR I
DOLLY GLASER. SKINNER. SKINNER.
I WILL HAVE WAHHAB, I WINNER
WINNER. I'M 5 TO 0. BILL REMAIN
ON CALL.
OK WE'RE GONNA, UH, LIFT THE
CALL. GO BACK TO ITEM NUMBER
FOUR S¼ B 1418. GO AHEAD. MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON TRANSPORTATION WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING I, SENATOR
SEYARTO, DOLLY GLASER, DOLLY I.
GLASER SKINNER. NOT THAT IS 4 TO
0. CLOSE THE ROLE. UH, NEXT IS,
UM ITEM NUMBER FIVE S¼ B 937.
MOSHIN IS THE PASSES AMENDED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON HOUSING WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING, SENATOR DOLLY
YEAH, I DOLLY I. GLASER SKINNER.
YES. UM, I SKINNER. I 6 TO 0.
OK, CLOSE THE ROLL. AND I THINK.
OK, WE'RE LIFTING THE, UM VOTE
ON CONSENT. MOTION IS ADOPT A
CONSENT CALENDAR. SENATORS DOLLY
DOLLY I. GLASER SKINNER SKINNER.
I'M 6 TO 0. CLOSE THE VOTE. AND
ON THE OH, NUMBER THREE. OK,
WE'RE LIFTING THE VOTE ON ITEM
NUMBER THREE S¼ B 1212 51 BY
SENATOR STERN MOTION IS TO PASS
TO THE COMMITTEE ON ENERGY,
UTILITIES AND COMMUNICATIONS
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I SENATORS
DOLLY GOLLY NÓ. GLAZER. UH, 52.
ONE. OK? CLOSE THE VOTE. OK? 955
SO, SENATOR DALLY. OK, UH, WE'RE
OPENING THE VOTE ON ITEM SIX S¼
P 955. BUT IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I SENATORS DOLLY DOLLY I
GLASER 60. CLOSE THE VOTE ON S¼
B 955. THAT IS RIGHT? THAT'S IT,
OK? THANK YOU. ON TRYING TO OK,
THANK EVERYBODY. OK, UM WE'VE
COME TO THE END OF THE MEETING.
THANK YOU TO EVERYONE WHO
PARTICIPATED IF YOU WERE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY, PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING. THERE IS ONE PERSON
LEFT IN THIS THAT THAT'S WHO I'M
SPEAKING TO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE END OF THE MEETING. UH,
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US. WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY. THANK
YOU FOR EVERYONE, YOUR PATIENCE,
COOPERATIONS AND TO THE
COMMITTEE AGAIN FOR ALL OF YOUR
HARD WORK. THANK YOU.